hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry and i'm
jessica welcome two reasons to see where
we give you reasons to sing hand not to
see iron man 3 so let's hang out reason
to see number one Robert Downey jr. he's
awesome he's a possum in this movie he
makes this movie you know what I mean
he's got the comedy down perfectly he's
got the emotional depth them perfectly
and this one you know he's having
anxiety attacks somehow he overcomes in
his ID through gigantic battles Robert
Downey jr. is Tony Stark because so much
of the character is synonymous with him
it's like he it's just Tony Stark's a
bigger version of Robert Downey jr. you
actually see more of elaboration of Tony
Stark building of his own character that
he's not just iron man yeah he's an
[ __ ] but you can still tell it's a
caring mother [ __ ] got a heart of gold
teeth all that's snark that snarky stark
yeah yeah I don't a teacher that's a
quote right there so weighty reasons to
see number two the action this moon
really explores a lot more of Tony
Stark's creative side like he has a suit
that's still and what it would a Jarvis
call it a suit it's more proteasome
Brooke it's a prototype and it's not
fully developed yet but he still manages
to be creative and figure out ways to
take down the bad guys it's a work in
progress and he's a work in progress and
together they make progress yeah they
were in their suits enacted a lot more
action yeah they do get to do some some
fightin side by side pepper yeah a
pepper too everyone gets to step up yeah
and kicking ass at one point or another
yeah every every movie now has a big
plane crash sequence are they use like
real skydivers for that scene that's
yeah crazy yeah they and there's always
humor in the action to which I really
like even there's not much action the
action is always creative always
entertaining to watch it's one of the
best reasons to watch this film is
really the actions great fragrances see
number three it's funny it's funny hey
dad look mainly just strives to be just
an entertaining flick he's really witty
in the movies you know honestly at times
though it though the humor did seem a
little bit like structure to me it like
sometimes it felt like line line now put
a joke there lime line now put a joke
here there's rarely a scene words like
yeah that's just a serious scene reason
to see number for the visual effects
come on siren little bit Marvel and
Disney have the money with the villains
and stuff there's this crazy like
biological fire thing I do and there's
lots of cool effects when they um you
know shot down his mansion yeah that was
great yeah when they shot down the
mansion that was some of the best visual
effects i've seen in a movie of long
yeah because it's hard to pull something
like that off and make it look very real
it all seems to be in the right tone the
right imagery RZA see number five ben
kingsley thankings lee he's cool in it
yeah i wish they showed him more in the
movie actually a little bit there's a
lot of unexpectedly handled things in
this video and he certainly wanted them
but every time he was on screen i was
enjoying his presence i was like thank
you for being here cuz i really did what
you're doing rc's gotta barely in the
[ __ ] movie you know yeah you look back
on it he's not really in it you know
what's like different about him so
usually he usually plays villains in
other movies or usually because more
serious role you see him in a more of a
comedic way you're like oh he's a lot of
fun to watch we use the scene number six
Rhodey I like more what they did with
Don Cheadle on this one they really gave
him a lot more comedy to you know I
think he's a lot more consistent with
the character
mm-hmm and I just like the chemistry
between Robert Downey jr. and Rohde you
know you don't get too much of it in the
film but when it's there it's really fun
to watch it's really it's great to like
just have it be in the bay you know like
they just some really funny stuff and he
kicked up he did he kicked a few acid
reason to see number seven guy pearce
it's funny because they introduced him
like he's a total dweeb yeah and yeah
immediately his next scene he's like the
most is super suit I he's like mr. suave
man you know I like Guy Pearce and it
seems like Hollywood hasn't done quite
what to do with him look I think he's
very underrated yes and I like seeing
him pop up and someone I liked that this
gave him a chance to do some kind of
character ething and a lot of ways he is
like the perfect match for iron man guy
Pearce's character steps in he's like
look at this [ __ ] you can see my brain
you know whatever yeah Thunder mentality
is a lot on the same level it's like yin
and yang a lot of ways yeah exactly when
you also see the action at history
reason to see number 8 Pepper Potts you
know it's cool they give her a lot more
things to do in this movie you know they
they put down his much screen time but
they gave her new stuff to do they put
her in situations that you don't imagine
Gwyneth Paltrow's character being
especially fast yeah she she delivers on
it like she does she sells it yeah what
is her status changes and her
relationship to Tony changes the things
that happen to her then change so in
this movie she is the bargaining yeah
peppers actually put in a really serious
predicament yeah yeah yeah very serious
you're like oh you're not just behind
the screen worrying about pine yeah get
your being worried about it does play
with that damsel in distress type of
theme but it also puts a twist on it at
the same time ii rages the scene number
nine the kid yeah man there's a whole
portion of movie words Tony and a kid
yeah and they're hanging out and they're
getting into trouble yeah this one you
see kind of get Tony being a little bit
of a father figure in some ways you know
it kind of it's kind of an abusive
father figure
somebody by his manager yeah they would
expect him to be God is like he's kind
of like you know like the the tough dad
figure in a way yeah but I know he's
like the combination of your dad and
your big brother yeah the movies that
try that [ __ ] it's always like corny
think it's annoying it's like it's like
[ __ ] that asian kid from Indiana
Jones to yeah I knew he had the same
humor or as not the same you were the
same witty sense as 20 * me please off
of Robert Downey jr. so well my reason
not to see number one doesn't take
advantage of iron patriot so we said
robeez or being technical about it yeah
Brody is a reason to see there's a lot
of hair splitting a tree since iron
Patriot's not a reason to see you though
you think oh yes you're gonna really
take advantage this time they picked it
up they keep sliding Rodion the suit
situations because it's like we see rody
in the suit but he's just on the phone
oh yeah and then he shows up in a
different point in the suit and then he
gets out of the suit and then kids know
anything cool with the suit like you he
shows up kicks the door up and it's
bunch of like you know Taliban woman
what do they call that it is people
working with sweat yeah I think if they
put him in his second Avengers I think
Joss Whedon will really know how to take
advantage of them yeah well cuz they've
left a room to work with his be elect
him all the room what reason have to see
number two uneffective drama and
intensity it took me a while to get
really pulled in where it was like that
was just it because for me this movie is
yes it's entertaining without a doubt
like you're even if they're just not
pull them but you're just observing it
it's an entertaining flight that's all
it really was was just an entertaining
flick yeah and it doesn't really have an
impact I know this isn't a movie that's
necessarily about the emotional depth
but there's a lot of stuff in here where
it's like I should feel more it may stop
that it also always look like the movie
itself doesn't give the characters time
to feel stuck yeah exactly there's
always something else they gotta go to
right now it's so it was strange because
it's like it's all there in front of me
yet a lot of its not being felt I felt
like they always went back to like oh
here's something that's going to be
effective but let's just go back to fun
yes entertaining fun but
seriously like it I do miss that I
really felt like I wasn't as pulled in
because of that split decision number
one mandarin ben kingsley does a good
job with the role they wrote of the
mandarin yes yeah does a good job I got
a big problem with how they portrayed
the Mandarin though because
split decision number to the ending okay
long leaving the post-credits king what
kind of both of after the finale and
post credits
WAW Ryan's consensus there are
entertaining reasons to see iron man 3
there are entertaining reasons to see
iron man 3 a lot of the you know awesome
intensity and dramatic pneus of a lot of
the Marvel films I love especially the
first in iron man but overall it's here
to entertain it's starting off the
summer and it delivers on entertaining
Jerry's consensus there are a lot of
reasons to see iron man 3 but not quite
as many as you would think there are a
lot of reasons to see iron man 3 but not
quite as many as you would think yeah i
mean it's it's got all this stuff it's
all there and it's a fun time too it's
good and for some reason wasn't fully
sucked into it you know um but I like it
go see it for sure you might I hope you
dig it Jessica's consensus cinematic fun
is the reason to see iron man 3
cinematics fun is the reason to see iron
man 3 yeah it's good action film but if
you're a comic with fan obviously you're
gonna be pissed I'm gonna be pissed but
in that it's gave you have a comic book
then I guess cuz people don't know
alright guys thanks for checking out our
show why don't you go ahead go to that
comment box below and tell us which one
is your favorite iron man out of the all
three have come out now and if you want
to check out more episodes of reasons to
see click the link right yeah if you
want to go ahead and click on the link
right here to check out the spoiler
review version of iron man 3 just click
that button right here and if you want
to get updated every time a new review
or video is out subscribe click on
Jessica yeah yeah yeah yeah click that
Asian button right there yeah but I
didn't ding ding ding you know I really
appreciate is they spelled iron man 3 t
hree at the end the thing just a little
thing it zooms towards greater oddly
that's kind of cool yeah there's a
little bit of
the ending credits like those ending
credits yes good yeah subscribe
subscribe subscribe to Jessica she'll
call you yeah we weren't opening up a
hotline a viral marketing yeah I is my
cousin and I want her to meet more
people so subscribe and she will talk to
you you're like a half a dearing half
really creepy pimp well yeah it's more
for money reasons there some more creepy
or more camp yeah more more creepy than
endearing yeah yeah yeah I'm going to
know yeah thanks you're still ahead
you